ED GLAESER: At the end of the 19th century,
the Russian empire was vast, poor, and largely agricultural.
Per capita income was about 1,500 modern dollars,
and the average peasant made do with much less than that,
suggesting poverty comparable to the more desperate parts of Africa today.
The average Englishman earned 4.6 times more than the average Russian in 1890.
Romanoff Russia was overwhelmingly rural.
Only 13.4% of the empire was urban as late as 1897.
This nation of 125 million souls had only two cities with more than 200,000
inhabitants in 1890.
St. Petersburg, with one million, and Moscow with 800,000.
And these were largely imperial cities, although, Moscow
had become the center of Russia&#39;s nascent textile industry.
Gradually, this backward giant was beginning
to industrialize and urbanize.
Russian weakness during the Crimean War taught the Czar
that rural societies have difficulty competing militarily
with industrial powerhouses, like England and France.
In 1861, Alexander the Second liberated the serfs.
This meant that peasants were, in principle, free to move to cities.
Although in practice, their former masters
still demanded significant payment in exchange for allowing their escape.
In the 1880s and 1890s, Sergei Witte tried to thrust Russia
into the industrial age.
Under Witte and Tsar Nicholas the Second,
Russia built railways even across the Siberian vastness.
Tariffs protected infant industries.
Foreign financing flowed into the empire and cities started to grow.
Kiev and Odessa both reached a half a million inhabitants in 1910.
These cities were built up by local magnets,
like the Brodskys, who were sugar barons like New York City&#39;s Havemeyers.
Ekaterinoslav, now Dnipropetrovsk, became a Russian Pittsburgh,
combining coal brought by rail from Donetsk,
and iron mined at nearby Krivoy Rog.
Ekaterinoslav, whose name honors Catherine the Great,
proved an early model for the Russian industrial city.
A formerly remote place with access to natural resources that became
connected to the wider world by railroads.
As the early anti modernization czars like,
Nicholas the First were well aware, cities pose risks to autocrats.
And revolutions broke out in Odessa and St. Petersburg in 1905.
[? Industriolwov ?] in Romanov controlled Poland rebelled as well.
Some farmers also rose up, but a general strike in the capital
is far more threatening that any rural contretemps.
The Romanovs survived that round of uprisings
through a combination of appeasement and repression.
But Nicholas the Second lost his throne and his life when St. Petersburg
rebelled not once, but twice, in 1917.
World War I had left the czars without enough loyal troops
to dominate the organized urban workers.
The revolution succeeded, just like most successful revolutions,
because the troops had lost their loyalty to the Czar,
and were unwilling to fire on the unhappy urbanites.
The chaos of the Russian Revolution shriveled Russia&#39;s great cities
and shrank per capita incomes to blow 1,000 modern dollars by 1921.
The population of St. Petersburg shrank from over 2 million to under 800,000.
Moscow&#39;s population dropped from 1.8 million to just over 1 million.
The new Bolshevik masters of Russia had to rebuild the economy.
Lenin&#39;s new economic policy was a profoundly mixed model.
More freedom for farmers to sell their surplus grain, plus state
owned heavy industry and a small entrepreneurial urban class of NEPmen.
Russia&#39;s incomes recovered to pre-war levels.
And the cities came back as well.
Since Moscow was now the capital, its imperial status
turned it into Russia&#39;s megacity, with a population that exceeded 4 million
by 1939.
When Lenin died and Stalin pushed his way to power,
this new red czar wanted his nation&#39;s industrial might
to rival the Western powers.
Starting in 1928, he instituted a series of five year plans
that would drive Russian manufacturing into the 20th century.
These five year plans made huge factories and cities that
were built to enable mass production.
Stalin didn&#39;t mind starving millions.
And he certainly didn&#39;t care about urban quality of life,
or perhaps, life more generally.
Many of the industrial cities were in the east to take
advantage of mineral deposits and coursing waterways.
During World War II, even more production facilities
were moved toward Siberia to avoid the threat of Hitler&#39;s Luftwaffe.
In some cases, Stalin&#39;s industrialization
expanded existing population centers.
Yekaterinburg had been founded in 1723 on the border of Europe and Asia.
Its name honored the wife of Peter the Great.
And it was where the last czar and his family were executed.
In 1933, it became the home of Ural Mash, the Euro heavy machine building
plant, which made blast furnaces, rolling mills, and cranes for mining
cities even further to the east.
It also built military materiel, including the famously durable T-34
tanks.
Further east, cities like Novosibirsk, the Chicago of Siberia, and Krasnoyarsk
expanded enormously during the 1930s.
Novosibirsk had only been founded in 1893,
but it was a natural transportation hub since it sat next to the bridge
over the mighty river Ob.
Krasnoyarsk is about 450 miles further to the east.
And it became a center of the gulag system,
where millions were forced to work in Stalin&#39;s factories and mines.
In 1956, Krasnoyarsk&#39;s industrial advantage
was increased by the opening of an awesome hydroelectric dam.
Stalin&#39;s industrialisation created a very special type
of city, the gulag city.
Population clusters around factories that
were developed by and for penal labor.
Norilsk may be the most extreme of Stalin&#39;s industrial towns.
It is the world&#39;s northernmost city with over 100,000 inhabitants,
and it did not even exist before World War I. Norilsk&#39;s great advantage lay
underground in vast Siberian mines that contain enormous amounts of nickel,
copper, cobalt, and palladium.
A railway was built to connect the city with a nearby port of Dudinka.
And from there, the minerals could be shipped by sea to Murmansk,
or up the river Yenisei to Krasnoyarsk.
Gulag labor worked Norilsk&#39;s mines under often horrific conditions.
More than 15,000 workers died from cold and starvation.
In 1953 after Stalin&#39;s death, Norilsk rose up in nonviolent protest.
Not much came of that.
The gulag system became slightly more humane under Khrushchev.
But these eastern industrial cities continued producing metal and machines
and misery throughout the Soviet era.
In the United States, rust belt cities like Cleveland and Detroit
suffer because their industries have shrunk or relocated.
The very success of those industries had crowded
out other local entrepreneurship.
And their locations are far from the sunnier
climates that most Americans prefer.
The problems facing Norilsk and Krasnoyarsk would seem to be far worse.
There never was any entrepreneurship in Norilsk.
And the climate is awful.
The air is terribly polluted.
After 1991, Russian mobility increased, and people and firms
were largely free to move.
Moscow alone restricted immigration, at least
nominally this migration offers the possibility
of eventually correcting any extreme geographic imbalances created
by Soviet industrialization.
Yet, Norilsk&#39;s population remains at 170,000.
Workers stay because the mines offer high wages, wages that are apparently
worth losing years of life for.
Novosibirsk and Krasnoyarsk continue to grow.
Russia remains highly dependent on natural resources.
And many of those resources are in Siberia.
It is hard not to think that eventually these cities will
see the same shrinkage experienced in the American rust belt.
If Russia becomes richer, and its economy shifts away
from natural resources, then Russians will presumably also
move to warmer, more humane, consumer cities.
Yet for now, Stalin&#39;s Siberian industrial cities remain.
Monuments to a Russia that cared more for industrial success
than for human life and happiness.